hey everyone its Mike from order flows
and in this video I'm going to explain
the order flows indicator 3-pack I'll
explain what it is and how to get it now
the order flows indicator 3-pack is a
set of three new indicators that have
taken us over six months to get ready
and these indicators do not overlap the
previous indicators that we have
released you know such as market
exhaustion and Delta scalper price
rejector these indicators are the order
flow is a V indicator the order flows
market flow trader and the order flows
tension indicator now before I dive into
it I'm going to show you a bunch of
charts but I'll just go through the
brief disclaimer understand that trading
is involves risk so first is the order
flows AV indicator and the order flows
AV indicator is a reversal based
indicator and it compares values in a
bar to bars before looking for areas
where value is being rejected now if you
have ever studied market profile
analysis you know that the market is
always searching for value then it finds
that value then it moves looking for a
new value as conditions change in trader
sentiment so you know on a footprint
chart alright you have to know what to
look for this is the order flows AV
indicator and it's telling me this red
line down here is the low of the day
it's telling me that you know the AV
indicator is kicking in telling me that
the value area is being put here and now
potentially the market is going to
search for a new value area and as you
can see you know it's coming in at this
bar and now I do have this trade entry
signal enabled so the signal is
appearing on the bar after the signal
bar and the market eventually goes
sideways unfortunately but then it
starts railing right the Imagine here
the low was what 40 the low of this bar
4900 low today is 48 99 and you see
rallied all the way up into the 49 50
areas shortly thereafter now you know if
you know how to read the order flow then
yeah you can understand what's happening
in here but if you don't know how to
read the order flow you don't know what
to make of what's happening you know in
the bar relative to the previous bars
now to make it simpler you know what
we've done is we've created this
indicator and it will run on a normal
bar chart so this is the order flows a
via indicator starting from Sunday
February 23rd
at 5:00 p.m. I'm gonna take you through
the entire week and as you can see
there's a signal over here I do have the
trade entry signal enabled so you'll see
some potential trades where it didn't
give an actual entry you know here's
another there's a buyer but I'm just
gonna take it through I'm not gonna
explain every single one and I sell now
this is the trade entry signal right the
conditions were met for potential trade
but there's no arrow drawn here meaning
that the trade entry signal did not give
an actual trade signal even though the
conditions were met if there was a
actual trade there would be the down
triangle and this is the e-mini
one-minute chart I'm just going to take
you through the entire week you know
this past week February 23rd until the
28th it was was a week unlike I've seen
in a long long time
you know the volatility in the market
was off the charts you know that we're
getting tremendous moves in all the
equity markets you know so if you know
you can survive that week you know
you're you're doing good but I want you
show this indicator worked on a very
difficult week for a lot of traders now
how some people use these zones is they
use them as their stop level
alright so they'll take the trade on the
up triangle or down triangle and they'll
use this little zone here this little
buffer as their stop placement but as
you can see you know not every trade was
a big winner there's some big winners
some small winners and some losses you
know this was a loss right here you know
but I want you to see that and
understand you know and again nothing is
100% in the markets you know I always
laugh when I see these advertisements or
these posts on Facebook oh yeah I have
my Forex system is 98 percent you know
who winning winning trades you can buy
it for nine ninety five or something
like that is crazy and unfortunately
people fall for that
you know trading is not an easy business
this was Friday already you see the
market was all over the place on Friday
especially so nice trends especially the
trend late in the day now notice it was
this big trend late in the day we went
from 2880 all the way up to 29 8100
point move in the snps in you know
basically a 15-minute time now there was
no signal here right the reason being is
because the order flow didn't give one
or you can only trade what the market is
giving you in terms of the order flow
alright so that's the order flows AV
indicator so the second indicator is the
market order flows market flow trader
and this indicator is based on the
ratios and divergence tools found in the
order flows trader footprint chart which
signal price defense and price rejection
now there are several ways of using
ratios with divergences and they are
incorporated into this indicator now the
way I teach people to use them is at the
highs and lows of the days but you know
you could also use them intraday and to
be honest the ratio and divergence is a
trade I'm always looking for because
it's what got me hooked on order flow
many many years ago when I discovered it
now on a footprint chart it's pretty
easy to see all right I yeah this is a
bunch art this is your divergence you
have your new low all right you got the
little green triangle there and you have
a ratio that you like a blue number
right my software was the first one to
put these numbers on there then other
vendors started putting you know they
figured out how to calculate the ratio
they started adding it on to their
software like oh we have the ratios but
they don't know how to apply it right
because it's it's not something that
they've ever used in their training you
know just because you know they saw it
on my software and you know there's a
lot of interest in it they said well
we'll just put it on there ourselves but
they never really taught people how to
use it and so I created this indicator
which takes the different ways I use it
I don't just use it at you know the high
of the day the low of the day is you'll
use it intraday you know in swings and
etc so let's go on the market flow
trader for last week February 23rd
through the 28th and you can see here
intraday right we started out that day
Sunday night we came in you know traded
lower started going sideways you
see some signals in here again I don't
want to go through all the signals I
think on this one I have the trade entry
signal turn on okay so you can see in
here the ratios that I'm using which are
this is the standard defaults that I'm
showing you right now on this indicator
let me just go up here you know this was
a losing trade here right but then it
came back at a nice winning trade some
small winners and this is a emini
one-minute chart you know here's the
cash open a nice big move again you know
last week you got these moves in these
equity markets that were really gigantic
this you know is to say the least you
know here's a nice trade starting at
5:00 in the afternoon 5:40 on Monday
that again I'm not gonna go as explain
all these trades I just want you to see
you know the where there were winners
where there were losers just so you can
understand the power of this this tool
now a question that I get is well if I
have these tools do I still need to
watch the order flow well I like to use
the order flow because I like to manage
the trade once I'm in it alright if I
start seeing things in the order flow
that aren't conducive to my position
then I'm going to cut it however if I
see things in the order flow that look
supportive um of my condition my
condition my position then I'll stay in
it longer alright what day are we on the
26 here again I want you to see this
tool and again this is just the default
settings right you can still adjust the
settings based on the way you trade
based on it in the markets that you
trade as well
okay now we're coming into Friday all
right so that's the order flows market
float trader
now the third indicator is the order
flows tension indicator and what this
does is it analyzes the orders traded on
the bid and the order flow traded on the
offer well it should be and finds the
bars where the traders are struggling to
take control of the market but
eventually one side takes control of the
market now this indicator can be used as
a reversal indicator as well as in
momentum it measures the order flow not
to the orders and let me get that
straight I just want to highlight that
to you right this is an order flow based
indicator so it's based on the trades
that go through so let me reread that
just there's no confusion it analyzes
the order flow traded on the bid and the
order flow traded on the offer not the
orders that were sitting on the bid or
the orders traded on the offer
right I like to look at what actually
trades in the market okay so on an order
flow footprint chart this is what it
looks like you can't it's hard to see it
in a bar like this right you have to
know exactly what you're looking for and
to be honest the way the markets have
been trading again this past week which
is you know honestly before this past
week the markets I thought had been
extremely volatile this past week is
just really you know something I haven't
seen in a long long time if ever you
know I mean I've traded through the
financial crisis of 2007-2008 even
before that you know the back in the 90s
with LTCM you know in Russia's default
and stuff like that
in the Bank of England and you know
other situations but what do you do what
we're seeing now is you know the things
that a lot of people have never seen
before
and so you're getting you know these
bars look at this bar in the e-mini is
29 we'll call it 29 33 to 20 and you
know that's a 10-point move in one bar
on a 1-minute chart in the e minis you
know back you know four or five years
ago this would be you know half your
days
range right here and now you're getting
that in one bar but anyway if you're
looking at the order flow on a footprint
chart it's difficult to see where the
tension is in the market you know you
see here's a cell up here there's a by
here here's another cell right and you
gotta know what you're looking for so
what we did is you know I took this
analysis and you know we put it into an
indicator all right so here you can see
the tension indicator okay I'll take you
through the week of February 23rd
starting on Sunday night okay nothing
really happened here just sort of kind
of quiet before all the fireworks happen
and here's starting to give some nice
cell signals okay here's a buy that
failed came right back with a nice buy
again some cells and some buys or sells
more cells back and forth there some
nice cells right before this you know
2:00 in the morning you know 50 point
move right there 2:00 in the morning and
in the SPS is pretty big
you know then right back up again
catches this move right here starting at
6:30 3100 on the 3060 and another big
monster move here from you know 30 80
I'm down to the close you know twenty
nine eighty hundred points in the SPS
it's crazy these the way these moves
have been you know I know I know a lot
of people have been making a lot more
money than normal but you know they've
had to widen their stops but they're
very good traders to begin with but then
again I know some people that have also
struggled because they're not used to
this volatility and they didn't realize
that they have to expand their their
stops you know they're entering an order
getting filled literally five 10 points
away from the last traded price then
they're finally getting the snow stopped
out you know within two seconds so
anyway this is the order flows tension
indicator now again what we've done is
we've taken what we see in the order
flow and we put it into an indicator
that will show up on a bar chart so
whether you're using an order flow
footprint chart whether it's my charter
or ninja traders chart it doesn't matter
you know you can still manage the trade
I prefer to manage the trade reading the
order flow you know you can use targets
as well
now this software rule
it runs on ninjatrader it will run on
the free version as well so you know say
you're using a different trading
platform to enter your orders you could
just download from the ninja trader
there free version load these indicators
on there but you will need a real-time
data feed if you're going to trade
through your other trading platform
that's what some people do you know I
know people that trade other markets not
just the US markets and what they do is
they get the free version a ninja trader
they load the indicators on they get a
data feed like from IQ feed or kinetic
and you know they trade that market but
they use the trading platform of ninja
trader so if you're interested in these
indicators what you do is you go to
order flows calm slash 3-pack tat HTML
the link is below in the description and
it'll take you to the page they'll show
you how to proceed on the next step so
thanks everyone for watching this short
video and have a great day bye bye